[Music]
you're watching the white and here's a
little taste of what we've got for you
on this picture
Pavarotti's is this what the next
generation of opera singers looks like
as swiping right killed romance I sit
down with a world-famous relationship
author and we're sending you into the
ring with extendable arms in our gained
review welcome to the show
I love it when technology makes the
unlikely likely for example take opera
singing robots uh-huh it's a thing but
how do you teach a robot to sing his
kids tucked away in this small rehearsal
room two new opera singers waiting in
the wings for their chance to shine
they may not look or sound like your
typical stage stars but over many months
this pair have been meticulously
reprogrammed to perform specially
composed opera hopefully could mark a
big step forward in the greater use of
robots in artistic roles here at the
IEEE 360 in Brighton the team behind the
project a busy fine-tuning their new
show how did you program these robots to
sing opera well it wasn't that easy
because these robots are designed for
education and research into human robot
interaction they're not designed to sing
I couldn't tell what sounds musical
sounds the robot would make if I set a
particular command to the robot so we
would have to actually try lots of
different combinations and listen to
them and then the composers with me
decided on which sounds were the
appropriate ones for the peace and
wirelessly this this computer sends the
program to the robot and from then on
the robots on its own it's acting
autonomously only a human intervening
every now and then to tell it when to
move to the next stage or producing
machines have been staged in the past
but this is thought to be the first time
that humanoid robots have been used
there was a deliberate attempt to help
them find their own voice
what is the robot soul if you like what
how can we really hear that I translated
the words that they would sing into
binary code and so they sing o1o
Oh 101 and then gradually that turns
into human language so I was trying to
create a bridge between the robot
language and the human the thought of a
simple machine replacing the demand in
an expensive opera star might be music
to the ears of theater directors but
critics of such innovations have warned
that you can never really replicate the
drama and emotion of the human voice I
still think that to replace a human
singer would be something that would be
a really really big feat and not
something I could see happening there
are clearly some challenging notes ahead
but it may not be too long before
classically trained tenors and Sopranos
have to start worrying about their new
digital competition you forgot your
scanners what do you reckon the future
of opera singing let us know tweet us at
Sky News swipe but don't go anywhere
because still to come
a former monk who went on to become one
of the world's best-selling relationship
authors has a warning about the way
technology is affecting our love lives
that's coming right up after a roundup
of some of this week's tech news Uber's
troubled chief executive travis kalanick
has quit after some of its top investors
demanded his resignation who has been in
a controversial spotlight recently with
questions over its working culture and
claims of sexual harassment electronic
glasses that claim to allow legally
blind people to see have launched in
Europe the makers of esight say it uses
a high-definition camera to capture what
a user is looking at before algorithms
enhance the video footage and display it
on two screens in front of their eyes
and Netflix UK has launched a feature
that lets children make decisions for
their favorite characters and create
their own story endings
stick around for our games review in
just a few minutes we've got what our
reviewer says could be the best racing
game ever but before that now for
something a little bit different swipe
is a tech show you know that so you're
used to watching us try out new
innovations to see if they might help
improve our lives but rarely do we look
at what happens when tech might not be
100% helpful one of the world's
best-selling relationship authors was in
the UK recently I went to meet him and
he had a lot to tell me about how he
thinks technology is affecting our love
lives John Gray is one of the
best-selling relationship authors of all
time he was once a celibate monk for
nine years that was before he became
famous for his men are from Mars Women
are from Venus self-help books in the
1990s back in the days when no-one had a
smartphone technologies had a huge
impact on the quality of our
relationship it's it's like a
distraction that absorbs us almost like
a bottle of alcohol you know you can
drinking is fun but too much is not a
good thing going online is fun it's good
but too much of it pulls us away from
the normal stimulation of a relationship
people don't understand that digital
electronic stimulation is similar to
drugs in terms of the brain chemical it
produces dopamine dopamine is that which
creates the brain chemical that creates
attraction between men and women but
when you're dependent when you're being
stimulated through the news all the time
and the Facebook and the massive amount
of information is coming in it
overwhelms the brain with dopamine so
normal stimulation of dopamine doesn't
affect us anymore and the same thing
happens with children today the best
babysitter is just give them an iPad and
let them play their games where parents
don't realize is too much of that
actually changes their brain just like a
drug addict it causes you to become
dependent upon high stimulation in order
to feel alive and normal stimulation is
kind of boring and flat so for the
younger generation and for the older
generation relationships are becoming
kind of flat and boring and people need
to do all kinds of
to sort of spice it up and create the
attraction again why women gain weight
after marriage and men don't John's not
anti-tech he's got a YouTube channel and
an online blog giving relationship
advice doesn't mean we can't have
technology and good relationships I'm
pointing out that with technology with
more women in the workplace women being
financially independent without
depending on a man with those new
challenges in our relationships new
skills can help us to resolve that we
all know dating apps a big business the
simplicity of flicking through profiles
and spotting faces you fancy but half
swiping right killed romance it's very
easy to just move on from one person to
the next to the next and it's important
to slow the whole process down and what
would slow the process down if women
would slow down it's like they have the
doors the man's job is to get earned the
key to open the door and for anyone
already through the doors and in a
relationship so what would your top
three tips for men and for women be to
survive and be happy in this stress and
tech filled world so three points for
men be good listeners plan dates and
show affection and if you're angry have
to have the fourth and if you're angry
stop talking and do something to rebuild
your testosterone your heart will open
and come back and be more loving and for
women the three points is when you see
your husband first time always be happy
to see him no matter what's going on
inside of you be happy to see him for a
minute and then ignore him just given
that message that he you're happy he's
alive men need that learn these new
techniques of how to share what's going
on inside of you but it's not about him
and number three you go in for the hug
and you appreciate him for all that he
does video games time now and when the
weather gets hot new releases tend to
dry out just a little bit it's what
happens at this time of year but our
reviewer Simon hasn't failed us pair
ears with three new title arms is the
latest game for the Nintendo switch and
as you may expect it is the most
Nintendo game you're probably ever going
to play in your life now the great thing
about this
if you decided to use the switches
motion controls you actually have to
hell' your arms around like you're in an
actual fight and on top of that the
motion controls are so sensitive if you
want to throw a right hook but make sure
it steers in towards the end you can and
you literally do it by flicking out your
right hand and twisting it and nothing
else is like that is no other fighting
game in the market that is like arms and
for that really good you're looking for
something unique you're looking for
something original and you're looking
for something Super Nintendo I can't
recommend arms highly enough dirt for
for the Xbox one ps4 and PC may not only
be the best rally game ever made but
there's every chance it's one of the
best racing games in the history of the
entire industry now while it can be a
bit drying a bit serious it replicates
what you'd see on TV or if you actually
sat in the car so well you can't help
but fall in love with it plus on top of
it it's incredibly easy for newcomers to
get to grips with it if you're looking
for something in-depth and something's
going to challenge you it's going to do
that too it can be incredibly hardcore
should you set it up that way
Codemasters has also introduced you
stage and as the name suggests that's
where you're able to create your own
racing courses tops toughness I highly
recommend it Tekken 7 as you may have
figured out is the seventh entry in the
Tekken series but because of that it's a
love led to the franchise in general and
a great fire all round now the best
thing about that is that Tekken has
looked at other games in the genre I'm
gone I want to do it like that
I'm Tekken I want to do it how I've
always done it and that's why it's a 3d
fighter surrounded by a bunch of other
games that stick to a 2d plane but
that's great you can actually sidestep
around your opponent and use that 3d
space to do combos and other moves you
may not be able to do in other games
it's also got an incredibly good
character customization option where you
can take your favorite fighters and
dress them up however you want Tekken 7
has always been at the forefront of the
industry and this one is no good
well that's it for this week's episode
why not follow us on twitter at sky news
swipe then you can see what we get up to
throughout the week and you can watch
any of our swipe episodes on demand and
all the usual places we'll be back again
next time see you then
[Music]